how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything marvel cinematic universe
last week we got the first
two episodes of one division and this
friday we are going to be getting
episode three
and although the reviews are absolutely
incredible and a majority of the fan
base
did love the first two episodes of one
division there are still a lot of
questions left
if anything we actually have more
questions now that we got the first two
episodes than we did before
just based off of the previews the two
biggest questions being
one how is vision back and two
who is ultimately behind everything who
is the villain
now we watched vision die in avengers
infinity war when thanos ripped the mind
stone out of his head
and then in avengers in game he wasn't
really referenced until the end where
wanda was talking to hawkeye
but that's it and then we just jump
right into one of vision with
vision being alive the first scene is of
them in the car and they just got
married but what happened
before this how did he get brought back
to life or
is he actually not really alive and
could vision actually be a part of the
villain's
ultimate plan to get wanda in this video
i'm going to break down three ways
the three most likely ways of how vision
has returned in the one division series
with the third one involving mephisto
the villain who i truly believe is
behind everything
and the reason i think vision is back
alive but let's start with the first one
which seems to be where everybody's head
and thoughts originally go when watching
this series
the first way that vision could be back
in the one division series is simply
wanda revived him she used her powers
and brought him back to life
and there could actually be a little bit
of evidence for this and the trailers
for the one division series
if there's one thing about vision that
avengers infinity war made perfectly
clear
is that there is a way for vision to
survive
without the mind stone bruce banner said
that there's a lot of things that make
up who vision is and the mind stone is
just one of those things
however vision does have the mind stone
in the wand division series
and in one of the trailers for one
division it does look like she is
tampering with the mind stone somehow
in the shot from one of the trailers we
can clearly see wanda working some type
of magic on what appears to be
the mine stone we can also see some of
the mine stones energy floating around
too
so clearly she is tampering with it
somehow now this
could be her restoring the mind stone
and possibly using it
and her powers to bring vision back to
life because if you think about it
vision is a synthesiod he doesn't have
organs that rot
since he died essentially what happened
is vision's power source got
disconnected from him but if wanda could
bring that power source back which is
the mind stone and just simply reconnect
it to him
then technically she could bring vision
back to life now this is something that
she actually does in one of her comic
story lines she searches
everywhere for vision's body and she
finds all the parts and reassembles him
and he gets brought back to life
and that could very well be what
happened here we just haven't seen it
yet
however i don't think that this is the
case let me start off by saying that one
division is
a lie everything that happens in one
division right now
is a lie it's a pocket reality created
in the real world but
isn't the real world so the only problem
with the logic
that wanda simply brought vision back to
life is the fact that she's in a fake
reality
why is she in this fake reality if
vision truly is alive
and division was truly alive he would
not accept this fake reality that wanda
put them both in
vision is too smart he would know that
this was bad however he doesn't really
seem to be in the know about a lot
his reactions are very underwhelming if
we really look at them
his reaction to her being pregnant is
barely a reaction and then when
everything changes to color he barely
reacts as well
and that's most likely because he's not
really back from the dead he's not
really alive which brings us to our next
reason of how vision has returned
which is he is an illusion wanda has
created
a fake reality in one division
everything revolves around the perfect
scenario for wanda
vision is back to life they live in a
super perfect neighborhood and
they are pregnant the people trapped
inside still have their own consciences
but are still in the fake reality not
knowing what's going on
and we've kind of seen hints at this
throughout different trailers and tv
spots that marvel has shown us for one
division in avengers infinity war she
lost
everything she had lost a lot before by
losing her parents and losing her
brother but then she lost her lover
so instead with carrying on through real
life she created a perfect life and a
different reality
and in that reality she brought vision
back but he's just an illusion he's not
really alive
this is a pretty good theory wanda can
create and control whatever she wants in
this reality but
she may not have actually created this
reality
and the reason we believe that is
because of the very last words spoken in
episode 2 of one division where the
sword agent asks wanda through the radio
wanda who is doing this to you which is
why i think
that the next reason vision could be
back is the actual reason
the third way i think vision could be
back is that he is actually the demon
mephisto this is kind of a two-parter
one because i think that he's actually
mephisto
or he could be controlled by mephisto an
illusion that mephisto created instead
of one that wanda created
now if you watch my past breakdowns on
the onenotevision series i think
mephisto is the true villain of the
series and
of the upcoming phase four in the comics
when wanda gets pregnant she finds out
that they're not
actually her kids they're actually the
shards of the soul of the demon mephisto
and he wants them back
in the one division series it's very
clear that children
are being emphasized and lo and behold
at the end of episode 2
wanda is pregnant but how did she get
pregnant vision
is an android he's not a real person now
you could argue that wanda simply made
herself pregnant however
she is very surprised when she finds out
that she is pregnant
leading us to believe that it's not
actually her who did it
it could be mephisto now whether or not
wanda created the reality or mephisto
created the reality
doesn't really matter because both seem
to have some type of control over it and
the reason i think that vision could
actually be mephisto himself is because
of a photo that marvel studios released
now as you can see here in this photo it
looks like wanda
and vision are about to fight each other
wanda has her powers at the ready and so
does vision flying through the air
now what could bring them to this level
of intensity well the fact that vision
could be mephisto
or is being controlled by mephisto could
definitely bring them there
marvel also just posted another tv spot
ad yesterday
which shows vision looking very angry
and kind of evil
and it also shows wanda in what appears
to be a fight mode
i personally think that eventually wanda
will figure out that mephisto has a
heavy influence on this reality
and he either is vision or he's
controlling him
now mephisto is actually going to have
some help in this reality and i think
it's in the form of the nosy neighbor
agnes whom we actually believe to be
agatha harkness
and if you really think about it agnes
is a shortened
abbreviated form of agatha harkness
agnes
it kind of seems like that one is right
in our face but this is why she is most
likely the nosing neighbor why is she a
nosy neighbor what does she want to know
about wanda
why is she always around and why did she
name drop the devil
who mephisto basically is well several
times throughout the first and second
episode of one division agnes
mentions her husband ralph however we
never
meet ralph we meet everybody else we
meet everybody else's husband everybody
else's wife but we never see ralph
even at the talent show for the kids
when all the husbands and wives were
there we just saw her sitting alone we
didn't see her husband
now this is very intentional you don't
just mention a husband
and not show him for no reason i believe
that ralph could actually be mephisto
and that agatha is working for him in
fact i think everybody in this bubble
reality is under some type of agenda
i think they're all actual people but
they're being controlled and this is why
in some of the trailers we see
a bunch of people all at once just look
at wanda
i think ultimately mephisto is behind
everything and he wants wanda to have
kids and then he wants the kids
why perhaps it's so he can take them
away and unleash
wanda that's kind of what happens in the
comics when wanda loses her kid
she slowly kind of starts to lose her
mental health then ultimately she alters
reality to a world where mutants
rule it which is what we could be
leading up to or perhaps maybe mephisto
actually wants the kids for some type of
reason we'll have to wait till more
episodes of wanda vision come out to
find out but in the meantime
let me know how you think vision has
returned for more mcu videos be sure to
subscribe and turn on the notification
bell so you don't miss any of them
give the video a like if you enjoyed it
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof